an unusual event the arrival of the
finance ministers of both Germany and
Italy at the Economic Affairs Committee
because in all that i can mention suzama
leben saw does develop sistema de tu
feelin under she gave them to have seen
we are going to a phase in which
different countries are in different
positions from the point of view of
their adjustment path some of them are
I've done more progress others have to
do more reforms are needed to jump-start
Europe sluggish economy that's the theme
of a report on the economic governance
framework by this member do for debate
in February why do we have to wait so
long before we are realized that we are
missing investment that the risk of
deflation is there that the use
unemployment is something we need to
tackle and so on and so on the Greek
election results shows that those most
affected by austerity are rejecting it
and it's not reducing Greece's debt the
most important thing is to give these
countries especially agrees a
perspective for the future do things a
certain the EU must act when there are
no quick fixes